[Music]
when you have nothing to draw from I was
able to find strength in every molecule
of this earth I'm able to be in a room
with nothing with no motivation no
inspiration nothing and find it I'm
gonna give you the most important
strategy that the next time you're
feeling frustrated you're feeling
defeated you're feeling like giving up
will save you and help you find that
inner strength and next gear I think
it's important that people find
something that gives their life a sense
of meaning and value that drives them
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up elimination it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message find your inner
strength over to you David Goggins also
if you want our david Goggins and others
have to say about confidence and
excellence
check out my 254 series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the links to join are in
the description below you will never
learn from people if we always tap-dance
around the truth everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today
[Music]
there's something that I invented a long
time ago
and when you have nothing to draw from I
was able to find strength in every
molecule of this earth I'm able to be in
a room with nothing with no motivation
no inspiration nothing and find it so
what I did in those situation was I
invent this thing called taking souls
when everybody's all up and you're
exhausted and you're weak and you're
tired and you're looking around and
everybody looks as bad as you or even
worse I'm like you know what I want to
now make a statement
it's the perfect time to make a
statement to make a statement to let you
know where your life ends and mine
begins and so the statement there is I
muster up every bit of strength from
their looks on their faces and how they
feel and how I'm gonna now from my
childhood where I came from how's the
bottom of the barrel I'm now amongst all
these uncommon people I'm now going to
now make you feel like you're common so
I used their their sadness their
weakness their parts of their life for
God this sucks I'm like all poopy pants
too messed up I used that for my
strength and I have this moment of like
let's say we're in the sand we running
or whatever I will do a surge I would do
something everybody how is he doing this
and from that that look on their face
that feeling of God man this guy must be
something something special it didn't
services me further and further and
faster and harder for a long time so
it's energies everywhere but the thing
is it's so loud that that that voice in
your head of pain and suffering and
discomfort and I don't want to do this
is so loud that you're unable to really
calm it down it's okay there's something
here it's a patient calm that you have
to bring your substitute I know I have
something here but that voice is so
powerful that it's once you just let's
leave right we're done we're done it
spazzes you out and you want to go first
you're saying let's take a second
hang on before we spaz to hang on and in
that moment you can think clearly and
find that strength out there for you I'm
gonna give you the most important
strategy that the next time you're
feeling frustrated you're feeling
defeated you're feeling like giving up
will save you and help you find that
inner strength and next gear
here it is tell yourself it's the best
the next time you're feeling down
frustrated depressed angry tell yourself
it's the best because now this is your
chance to show yourself and the world
what you're made of the next time you're
stuck at a red light and you're
frustrated and complaining it's the best
the next time you're working out and you
feel like you're on your last scent your
your lungs are on fire and you can't
push again it's the best the next time
you're frustrated in business that
you're not getting the sales you need
and you feel like waking up every day
and there's no momentum it's the best
it's the best this is your chance this
is your chance you can complain for
seven and a half seconds and get
frustrated and then tweak it inside your
brain to say this is the best why what
does it do
first it switches your mindset to one of
hopelessness to one of the
resourcefulness it switches your mindset
from one of hopelessness that this sucks
that I'm giving up I'm defeated it's
over why does this happen to me why does
this suck to one of resourcefulness that
this is the best this is my chance
because you grow through challenges and
this is the next challenge in front of
me that I am going to grow through
here's an example I'm on a flight from
Vancouver to LA and the guy next to me
stinks just stinks okay
he's probably been on three or four
different layover hadn't slept in
forever and just really smells and I'm
sure he's a great guy but he smelled
really badly and I'm sitting next to
when it's a full flight so what are my
options not make my speaking gig in LA
does not show up get off the plane no am
I gonna be pissed off the whole time
there and then that's a five-hour flight
be upset then and then when I get there
I'm still upset and it ruins my whole
day no I'm gonna say this is the best so
I complained for seven and a half
seconds this smelly dude next to me I'm
gonna sit next one for five hours and
then what do I do
breathe it in it's the best because that
smell the guy is not stronger than me
because I'm teaching myself that I can
grow from this that this is not the edge
of my capabilities that's sitting next
to some smelly guy for five hours is not
the edge of my capabilities I can do
more this is the best this is my chance
to show myself in the world what I made
of it's the best so try to catch it you
won't catch you most of the time it's
okay you can be gentle on yourself in
that part but when you do catch it when
you catch yourself feeling frustrated
sad down depressed tell yourself this is
the best and what would the strongest
most resilient version of you do and
then go do that thing and become that
person now I've got a really special
bonus script that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question of the
day I want to know what do you need to
say it's the best - right now in your
life let me know put in the comments
below
first time I stood up to speak I stood
up in my mind sat down I choked I
couldn't remember anything you know I
spoke in the Georgia Dome I went to the
bathroom seven times did I tell you
seven is my lucky they knocked into a
brownie I said what is it come out man
Dexter Yeager they up there pausing now
because it's time for you and I made a
mistake I looked out at the audience and
I panicked I said Mike I don't hear the
voices I'm scared
he said brownie they came to see you you
didn't come to see them he said come out
you were here the voices I said I don't
know Mike I've been trying I just don't
know
I'm scared and he said just be scared
and do it anyhow don't speak I said I'll
help speak he said no I said then what
will I do he said just tell a story mmm
tell a story of where you are about what
you're going through and about the goal
and dream for buying your mother home
and so my vision of myself of wanting to
buy her home and and be able to provide
for her and I did that at four bought
four different homes before she passed
that that drove me and so I think it's
important that people find something
that gives their life a sense of meaning
and value that drives them that becomes
their magnificent obsession if you want
more David Goggins check out the top 10
rules video I made on him the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there fat out of shape is secure
I was everything everybody said I was
going to be